[Música]
é o meu chapéu é o alto do céu
o meu chapéu é o alto do céu
o meu chapéu tá no alto do céu estre
domingos cá de seu chapéu
seu domingos cabeceou chapé meu chapéu é
um alto do céu
o meu chapéu tá no alto do céu é o meu
chapéu é o alto do céu meu chapéu da no
alto do céu
mestre domingos cá de seu chapéu meu
chapéu é o alto do céu
seu domingos cá de seu chá pé é em meu
chá mestre joão ba onde é que tá seu
chapéu meu choque o meu chapéu está no
alto do céu meu chapéu é nesta assim
aonde é que está seu chapéu
assim aonde é que está seu chapéu no
chapéu é o alto do céu meu chapéu
tablado no céu s tinha onde é que tá seu
chapéu
o meu chapéu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nenhuma outra boa também pra gente é é
um john o nome nem o albertinho acho que
aprendi com assim a rosário que aprendeu
com a raquel trindade abert inad acho
cadê meu melhor vocês responde a galinha
com meu a galinha comeu o meu melão tão
madryn albedina dia a escada e milão a
galinha o meu milan tão madrinha galinha
o meu a galinha
era meia-noite eu saí a procurar o
galinha piro albertino fácil eu ia achar
era meia noite eu saía procurar o
galinho piro albertina solta a franga
aqui no peru
albert nadj acho que já sei como fazer
um negócio aí todo mundo se soltar só tá
mesmo eu fazer um marco ao galinho metrô
em um único que esse teatro que já viu o
inédito a gente até de petistas jacques
aí quando eu ficava betina de academia
mas só dá mesmo gente da casa contra ele
entendeu eu vou fazer isso a gente só
está na cabeça negócio que visa fazer
esta crise que afasta albert nadj acho
que cada mil bebês
[Aplausos]
a galinha com meu hd para o meu milan
não madure a galinha eu era meia noite
muito bonita e sexy excepcionalmente
excecional
muito obrigado isso aqui é um jogo é um
jogo eo fluminense
eu aprendi com a querida assim a roçar a
música diz que eu vim falar com vocês
aqui viu
é quando me convidaram pedido para
contar um pouco da minha história né
é que com as figuras lindas que eu já
encontrei nessa minha caminhada de
músicos e produtores sonhador
pesquisador e eu quero dizer a vocês que
está junto com essas figuras com essas
pessoas é um aprendizado muito grande
uma troca muito linda que eu tive
vou começar um pouquinho introduzindo é
e como eu comecei com a música que foi
dali que começou
é um tempo bom tempo atrás uns 15 16
anos atrás decidi como irmão comprar um
violão
a gente comprou junto esse violão mas no
fim das contas o irmão nem costumes
violão eu gosto dele era com a sua alta
aí eu peguei esse violãozinho e ficava
de noite né estudando ele
tudo por conta das duas aulas nem
consegui muitos o joão é joãozinho da
escola é só com ele e aí eu fiz duas
aulas mas já me deu um nó tenho bem
bacana aí eu comecei a mexer com
gravação
comecei me encantar por essa
possibilidade da gente gravava uma coisa
vou gravar outra e na época enquanto
gravava tudo um gravadorzinho cindy fita
depois eu colocava para tocar o que eu
gravei para ouvir aquilo e gravar num
outro gravador que estava tocando em
cima
tipo assim ó
[Música]
i e ii beleza né
imagina eu hoje é fácil né tá fácil
pegar os índios e põe aqui em qualquer
lugar você pega solta aqui aprendendo e
aí com essa possibilidade de gravar
gravar eu encantei com esse universo
começa a gravar
aí então eu comecei a tocar viola
ao tocar viola pesquisar as raízes da
viola procurar quem já estava fazendo
isso faz tempo eu acho que na verdade é
um conselho que eu dou pra mim é uma
coisa de que atrás né além de ter essa
liberdade de inventar mais pneus em
conhecer nossas raízes né então foi
atrás de um grande mestre que mora aqui
em campinas que eu conheci fiquei
sabendo que havia um mestre de folia de
reis aqui e aí fui atrás dele morava
perto da minha casa por 5 a 1 incidência
do destino é procurei semestre não
achava ele em que esta se querem ou não
consegue ficar parado minutos e e sempre
mexendo com muita coisa com horta com
gente com tudo
já o mineiro é mestre folheia catireiro
já foi pastor evangélico mas de santo a
pessoa múltipla incrível ver se eu
conhecer a vila brandina no chão e aí
continua mineiro e eu não consegui achar
ele foi atrás pra conhecer a folia de
reis comércio chão eu andei muitas casas
não têm muito nas periferias de campinas
muitas casas na roça e testar a honra ea
alegria de uma coisa que eu recomendo
vocês andar com uma folha de reis é de
noite é dia e noite a partir de dezembro
já começa até janeiro até o dia de risco
e aí eu tive essa alegria de andar com
ele me puxou e brincar comigo você quer
aprender umas coisas vêm cá e uma figura
muito introvertido muito divertido
aprendi muita coisa a aprender até hoje
né ea gente troca um grande parceiro e
amigo bom fiquei sabendo que tinha
mineiro tinha muitas composições dele e
eu comecei a mexer com gravação naquela
época
mas começando já a mexicana começou a
mexer com gravação e aí eu peguei e
falei assim um bom chão
você tem muita música né e então mostra
uma música pra mim comecei a notar a
escrever e vi que tinha um repertório
fazer um cd bom vendo aquilo que falei
não tem que ajudar este é o primeiro
cigarro é uma figura uma meta tão
querido
vou atrás e fui atrás e conseguimos um
projeto para gravar o cd ele tinha essa
alegria e honra de produzir fazer os
arranjos é de se discutir uma coisa com
os passarinhos começa em janeiro
gravei e pronto nós fizemos dois shows
nem pensar como é que a gente grava cd
músico grava cd faz três shows de
lançamento quando não tem uma produção
assim brava aí vai receber em andar de
baixo do braço onde vai vender um aqui é
uma dificuldade
aí bom isso seria do tião saiu fazendo
alguns shows e tal e aí na sequência com
esse joão ba joão baú ninguém vai
lembrar que ele é menino
apesar de se dizer alemão em uma
brincadeira que ele fala do dia liguei
pra ele foi foi bom dia 7 ao boa noite é
bom dia boa noite para encostar no avião
que aqui na alemanha
a noite ainda vai ser a figura e aí com
esse joão ba baiano a shin
samba nasceu no sertão da bahia
daqui um jesus
[Música]
joão ba nasceu em 1932 tempo e aí
cantando e compondo e criando conheci
joão ba liguei pra ele pra pedir
autorização para gravar uma música dele
o meu segundo cd celebrações ninguém
para joão ba é todo assim é o que me
passou o contato foi 10 max muito grande
e méxico de alegria de conhecer meu
caminho
ninguém vai jogar e foi muito engraçado
porque ele é uma figura incrível também
liguei pra ele atendeu a roubar ele
sempre gritando onde ele está e atende
telefone que está no restaurante há ao
todo mundo olha posso jogar tudo bem
aqui joão arruda só busco violeiro
compositor gravando um cd já enfatizou
dia rodeia o seu joão o seguinte fazer
falar com você sou admirador do seu
trabalho da sua obra
eu queria gravar uma música que chegou a
ferir pode gravar é tudo nosso é uma
pessoa tão generosa né
é tudo nosso pode gravar afi o senhor
joão eu tô aqui gravando fazendo
independente não tem muito recurso
dinheiro tal é massificar tranqüilo se
tiver uma única ficha limpa ajudar a
manutenção a gente aceita mas se não
tiver também tem problema
seu amigo do dest marketing que conta
tudo certo e pode gravar eu falei hoje
um baque bom então eu preciso uma
autorização do senhor hoje está
atualizado falando que não são joão a
seguinte de uma autorização de mandar um
e mail que o senhor acha e meio tem
senão aí eu jamais tem alguém que pode
ajudar uma filha não fique assim ele tem
assessora produtora-executiva nossa
artista né
aí falei tá bom jogo para o telefone
liguei ligado conversando tal começamos
uma amizade muito legal depois daqui
aí liguei pra essa pressa assessora
produtora executiva
liguei pra ela ela consultório
odontológico boa tarde
é é da produção do senhor joão ba
ela é
já entendi você é só a dentista bem mas
posso ver que você precisa
falei 'bom eu sinto uma ajuda uma rodada
na roda que é preciso uma autorização da
mãe cadeira alguém combinamos e tal uma
autorização para ver música
e aí nós temos uma parceria muito grande
depois de um certo tempo joão ba
me diga o dia aqui na rodoviária de
campinas
aí no meio do ensaio na correria nossa
do dia a dia
nossa joão que alegria que bom toque em
campinas que os livros aqui de alguma
ajuda uma coisa não fez o esperado aqui
na rodoviária é tá bom então é por aí
falei pessoal que estava em san foi
gente vou lá buscar o mestre joão
batista aí tá aí cheguei lá também como
o chile em uma mala no buffet do hit
figura com 86 anos chegou entrou no
carro a rotina foi o feijão faz tempo
que chegou e faz como as quatro horas
que eu estou conversando com a ajuda
aqui do café o podcast que foi sendo
elas vendiam disco nossa figura né
aí beleza o senhor joão então vamos pra
casa cheguei em casa tal e sentamos o
fato então já o show do filho a mãe
mandou embora com ela
ela não me quer mais a não mandou aí eu
vim pra cá o senhor ser uma coisa senão
eu vim aqui pra gravar um cd roupa mesmo
começou a mostrar canções inéditas
comemorando os 80 anos ele pode não
vamos dizer o projeto passou o tempo nem
vou tentar resumir a campanha meu tempo
e aí passou um tempo
gravamos e depois de um tempo vejam
balançando a rede depois do cd gravado
já a gente fazendo parcerias
joão barreto toca o telefone para que eu
já vi aquela cena nem frio então
autorizado não é tudo nosso
a manutenção é bom mas não bota e meio
não tem não
a band ea produtora executiva
a rodinha fala com ele aqui quer pedir
autorização e assim me tornei assessor
amigo parceiro empresário tudo em um bar
le bon joon batiam joão ba e agora sim
arroz
sim a usar a figura também dos seus 84
anos agora é através de um projeto do
pessoal da unicamp do coletivo fábio
grafias é é levar lá pro estúdio assim é
pra gravar um projeto uma uma exposição
e aí foi uma ideia bem legal que juntou
assim a com um grupo um trio de música
instrumental de improviso que fazia
provisto bueno chegou assim à rosário
com essas figuras rolou um som incrível
maravilhoso e assim a começou a falar
das composições dela das coisas que ela
tem feito e escrita e tal se a tem muita
história muita história na verdade os
três são figuras com muitas histórias e
aí assim ele mostrou todo o trabalho o
repertório dela e aí na hora foi um
sinal de que já vai sendo assim é
gravamos seria assim é e aí nesse
processo eu estava com três trabalhos é
de três figuras incríveis que eu tive a
alegria ea onde cruzaram seu caminho mas
aquela é aquele lema e agora né
aí eu te amo e falava o dia vamos fazer
um show do cd foi vamos te amo e estou
conseguindo conseguir fazer mil direito
vai dar certo assim a holding e vamos
fazê lo chamando e joão ba aonde vamos
fazer um show
vamos então fazer a gente estava sentado
na beira de um rio x 3 x 3 no chão só
junta três em um termo de 31 filho rocha
daí pensei roda de mestres bom vai dar
bom primeiro ensaio convidei os 3 xe foi
uma química tão linda tão emocionante
tão forte que depois vocês podem
procurar tem roda de mestres lá só que
tem muitas muitas rodas e muitos messi
foi a roda de mestre
esse pronome de joão ba o meio de uma
rua que aí vincula bom e um show
maravilhoso line
é muita alegria muita muita emoção
partilhar essas coisas tão lindas com
essas pessoas e poder levar público
emocionar tanta gente
joão ba com a sua poesia do sertão
baiano com sua força da poesia e da
cantoria nordestina
se a rodada com a força do samba do bom
samba lenço jogos
e outras brincadeiras ambas mil que o
mineiro com as folias de reis e aí fomos
à roda de mestres mas o que eu pra
arrematar isso aqui juntar tudo assim eu
acho que eu posso dizer para vocês o que
eu aprendi o que eu aprendo cada dia
porque cada dia que passa eu tô com
essas figuras ainda graças a deus está
andando bastante fazer um show e
convivendo muito além de tudo é que
assim essas pessoas esses mestres que
carregam tanta força tanta tanta
ancestralidade tanta tanta música tanta
cultura
eles precisam de ajuda também eles
precisam que a gente vá ver os músicos
artistas vão conhecer um trago mistura
isso é lindo e maravilhoso mas também
precisam da gente troque uma troca
bonita que mais aprendi foi essa troca
com essas figuras eu cresci muito e
acredito que eles também apesar de serem
grandes já também a gente aprender muito
comigo e assim a gente segue né
caminhando juntos nessa roda e aí eu
espero que um dia eu encontro uma
rodinha quando ficar mais velho enquanto
uma rodinha alguém que gosta do trabalho
que mim que goste de mim nem da minha
obra do que eu fiz o que eu faço e posso
trocar comigo também ea roda continua a
girar com essa roda bonita dos mestres
das mestras continuar girando e agente
semear coisa boa pra esse povo esse
mundo está cada vez mais precisa né
então queria agradecer acho que está
dando meu tempo aqui muito obrigado a
todos eu queria só fazer um negócio aqui
com vocês a gente embora que não tá nem
canta pouquinho e trouxe a viola que
quer fazer um verso de folia de reis
maior coral de folia de reis disse que
até já viu
eu vou cantar um versinho só da folia de
reis e aí no final do verso a gente abre
volta
não havia um velho uma resposta não pode
deixar na praça inglesa ai ai ai ai ai
[Música]
o povo acompanhar
i
[Música]